Let me tell you a little bit more about the format for this class.
We'll have a lot of lessons that are interspersed with quizzes quite liberally.
So you'll have a chance to practice the ideas that we're teaching you
as we're teaching them to you.
In addition to that, we'll have mini projects at the end of each lesson.
And in my opinion, this is where most of the learning will happen.
This will be where you get your hands on the keyboard and
you actually practice coding up the things that we're teaching.
And to that end, it's very important that you have a computer that has
Python working on it because that's what you're going to need in order to
complete those mini projects.
At the end of the class, we'll have a final project that ties together
pieces from a lot of those mini projects into one big machine learning analysis.
And this is really cool and really exciting.
And this will be the way that
you know that you've learned something really concrete and really fantastic.